[Music]
the release date for Captain America new
world order has been fixed the fourth
Cat movie is scheduled to hit theaters
on May 3rd 2024 while there's still more
than enough time until then there has
been an increasing amount of information
about the new Captain America from
Marvel in recent months in order to save
you from having to read through the
entire web we have already done the work
and compiled everything that is known
who will be in the film who will be the
new villain and what kind of connections
will be made to other new Marvel
releases all these interesting questions
are covered in this week's Original
Episode so keep on watching
as you can guess from the date alone New
World Order will be set at the end of
phase 5. we cannot yet say for sure what
conditions will prevail in the world
until then after all movies like the
Marvels and the Disney plus series
secret Invasion will surely leave their
mark on Earth phase six of the MCU will
kick off shortly after with Fantastic
Four so it may very well be that we will
already see one or two teasers for the
new set in Captain America 4. if we
focus on the antagonist then the series
She-Hulk could also be relevant for the
film but more on that later
as most of you probably know the shield
of Captain America was passed on from
Steve Rogers to his good friend Sam
Wilson AKA Falcon the story of how he
eventually becomes Captain America is
told in the series Falcon and the Winter
Soldier which we will briefly discuss if
you have not watched the series yet you
should skip ahead to the next part as
this one will contain some spoilers in
the beginning Sam did not want The
Shield at all and gave it back to the US
government the latter also seemed to
have no interest in a black American
carrying Captain America's shield
instead John Walker was to become the
new Captain America this drives a wedge
between Bucky and Sam since the latter
had not granted Steve's last wish to
become Captain America on top of that a
new organization is threatening the
world order the members call themselves
flag Smashers and they wish to restore
the world to its state before the blip
they obtain a serum similar to the one
given to Steve during World War II as
they find out there are more super
soldiers in the world including Isaiah
Bradley also an African-American who
helped the government during the Korean
war in the end Falcon and Bucky
succeeded in stopping the organization
and Sam accepts his role as the new
Captain America
especially when it comes to the cast
there is some interesting news for
example there are some actors from the
MCU that we are already familiar with
who will play in the film one returnee
is making it back into a Marvel
production for the first time in 16
years those who have already checked the
cast list we'll also have noticed that a
couple of names are missing who no
longer play a part in the story around
cap
but enough talk and let's get into the
details one thing that is already
certain is of course Anthony Mackey in
the role of Sam Wilson or from now on
better known as Captain America when the
movie premieres it'll be exactly 10
years and one month ago that Falcon
joined his friend Steve Rogers to
destroy Shield or rather Hydra we also
got to check out his suit in the last
episode of Falcon and the Winter Soldier
unlike Steve he naturally also has his
wingsuit at his disposal besides all the
white and red colors resemble even more
the flag of the United States
along with Mackie Danny Ramirez and Carl
Lumley are also back in the cast Ramirez
played the CIA agent Joaquin Torres who
already alerted Sam to the flag Smashers
in the series you'll most likely have a
similar role in the movie even if the
enemy organization is a lot more
powerful and dangerous with the New
World Order Carl Lumley AKA Isaiah
Bradley is also expected to reprise his
role the super soldier who is getting a
bit long in the tooth will surely no
longer actively intervened in the battle
but he will certainly help the young cap
with words and deeds new to the series
is Sabra whose real name is Ruth bad
saraf we may already see the young
Massad agent in secret Invasion as she
plays an important role in the
corresponding Comics the Asian
disembodied by the Israeli actress Shira
Haas who was last featured in the
miniseries unorthodox the fact that
Sabra is now being introduced in the MCU
is again a reason for many comic readers
to prick up their ears after all at
least in the comics not only is she an
agent but she's also a mutant after the
Cameo appearance of Charles Xavier in
Multiverse of Madness and the mentions
of mutations in Ms Marvel clues about
the X-Men and the MCU are becoming more
and more obvious
the bad guy is already part of the
film's title similar to Hydra it is
again not just a person but a whole
organization the eponymous new world
order this was founded early on by The
Red Skull and settled in the jungles of
the Amazon after years they tried to
manipulate the Hulk by brainwashing him
which they succeeded in doing for a
while however in the end Hulk Broke Free
from it and crushed the organization
along with the help of the Avengers
although they managed to reorganize a
short time later they were finally
destroyed by Apocalypse in the new movie
the organization is also joined by a
familiar face or rather a villain we
have not seen since the Incredible Hulk
we are talking about Dr Samuel Stearns
AKA leader as in the 2008 film he is
played by Tim Blake Nelson there he was
responsible for turning Emile Blonsky
into Hulk's enemy Abomination at the end
of the film he got some of Banner's
blood himself and its head began to
swell to this day Marvel has not
Incorporated this again fitting with
this announcement are also the rumors
about him being behind the attacks on
Jennifer Walters AKA She-Hulk in
addition to telepathic abilities leader
also has robots similar to Tony Stark
and Ultron in the comics which he built
himself and who fight on his side either
way we are very excited to see the new
old villain
unfortunately one character is no longer
part of the movie and this will surely
disappoint all fans of Falcon and the
Winter Soldier Sebastian Stan as Bucky
Barnes is sadly not featured in New
World Order especially the lack of
relationship between the two who are the
closest allies of Steve Rogers now
causes fans to feel more heartbroken yet
he has not gone from the franchise of
course while Sam fights alone against
leader Bucky plays an essential role in
the film Thunderbolts which will be
released shortly after not part of the
movie either will be Chris Evans as
Steve Rogers contrary to all rumors he
is stated via Twitter that there will
only be Sam
rumors of whether Emily Van Camp will be
back once again as Sharon Carter also
remained to be confirmed at the end of
the series spoiler alert it turns out
after all that she is the notorious
Crime Boss power broker it would be
appropriate that Sam is again dependent
on her help in some way when he once
again has to destroy an organization but
as mentioned nothing has been confirmed
nor denied so far
since the film is currently still in the
early stages of development there is not
that much information about the
production yet but there is a change of
director since the previous directors of
the Captain America movies namely Joe
and Anthony Russo are busy with other
Productions Julius Ona will take over
the nigerian-american filmmaker last
directed the drama loose which was
released in theaters in 2019 set to
return a scriptwriter and showrunner is
Malcolm Spellman he's the man who
previously wrote the story around Sam
Wilson on Falcon and the Winter Soldier
further information about the production
is sadly not available to us yet however
you can find all the future updates
about Captain America 4 New World Order
in our news video which is published
every Saturday
as with the production not much is known
about the plot so far one of the main
issues here is that there is no cap
centered comic story on which the
creators can rely thus creativity is
needed one rumor that has already gained
Traction in fan circles is that there
might be a return of the Red Skull after
the Soul Stone was destroyed there is
nothing left for him to protect on
vormir hence he may return to Earth to
run the organization he founded after
decades or maybe it has not been
established yet and he takes over this
job with Dr Samuel Stearns as his first
henchman he is also immediately found
someone who carries enough hatred
Against The Avengers it is also
conceivable that they try to turn caps
allies against him by means of mind
control as in the comics at this point
it would become interesting to see
whether John Walker makes another return
it surely does not take much to put him
in a position against Sam since the
latter has unwillingly outstripped him
as Captain America here we could also
easily picture the power broker when
voluntarily gives the resources of the
underworld into the hands of the New
World Order however it will probably
take a while before we know anything for
sure after all filming on the movie is
not scheduled to begin until early 2023
and before the first set photos are
released we can only keep speculating
for example in the comments down below
alright that was all the info there is
on the fourth part of Captain America so
far is there anyone else from the MCU
you would like to see in the cast and
what are your thoughts on the plot let
us know in the comments and if you like
this video be sure to give it a thumbs
up
thank you
foreign
[Music]